now you'll probably remember when boris
johnson talked about easing lockdown it
was all going to be about data
not dates and specifically actually uh
there were four tests that the
government was going to look at to see
whether we could ease lockdown on those
dates that it had
prescribed so these tests it's worth
just going through them to see
how we're doing are we doing better than
expected worse than expected and the
first of them is about vaccine
deployment basically are we getting
vaccines
in arms quick enough and on this front
actually things looking
pretty promising these bars here show
you different age groups
in england and how much they've been
vaccinated and what i'll do is i'll just
show you the average and over 90
of those aged over 70 in england have
been vaccinated when you look at the
data on cases
we're starting to see some encouraging
numbers on this have a look at this this
shows you
the change in cases by age groups and so
what i've got here is
under 70s and over 70s and you probably
can't really see that much difference
here and that's because
this chart is one of those kind of
charts with a regular axis that focuses
mostly on that the peak over there
but what i'm going to do is just convert
this to a logarithmic axis you might be
familiar with them we had a lot of them
early on
in the pandemic and what it means is we
can kind of focus in on that lower bit
there see what's happening in terms of
the dynamic of growth
down there and if we do that that's
converting the axis same data
by the way just have a look you've got a
real divergence here between
under 70s so those potentially who
haven't been vaccinated for the most
part
and over 70s over 70s cases continuing
to fall
under 70s starting to plateau so that is
really encouraging
for the vaccination effort and that's
just based on the case data that we're
getting through
but there are concerns about where the
way vaccinations have
been distributed amongst ethnic groups
and let's just have a look at some of
that data this this is from the ons
as well and this just breaks it down by
different ethnic groups and over there
you can see white british
over 90 91
but just have a look here black
caribbean black african 69 59
so a big divergence in terms of ethnic
groups and how much they've been
vaccinated and that's causing some
concern
among the public health community but
broadly speaking when you look at that
first of those tests all the vaccines
being deployed looks pretty encouraging
doesn't it
the second test is whether those
vaccinations are reducing
hospitalizations
and deaths and you saw that case chart i
showed you a moment ago
let's do the same thing for
hospitalization specifically
and here again a similar picture so
under 65 over 65 the white line is under
65
black lines over 65 so what you're
hoping for is to see a bit of a
divergence here between the two lines
and again what we're just showing you is
the change in hospitalization so you've
got the peak
they're at the same number for the peak
and then what happens to their growth
afterwards
again i'm going to change it to a
logarithmic axis so we can really focus
in on growth rates down there
and here's what you see there is a
divergence here so that's pretty
encouraging
over 65 hospitalizations falling faster
more continuously than under 65s for the
time being
it's very early uh but so far that does
look encouraging and that's test two
whether they are actually
uh successfully uh reducing those
hospitalizations so that's looking
pretty good on test two
how about some test three you can see
infection rates
they do not risk a surge in
hospitalizations now that's basically
that big question of whether we're gonna
see
start things start to increase when
people go back to school and you'll
probably remember
you know children going back to school
we were going to look at the data see if
that pushed up case rates and then
take a call as to whether we could go
ahead with the next easing let's have a
look at what that date is actually
showing us
that's when schools reopen march the 8th
this is kind of grown-ups so anyone over
school
school age and you can see that their
case numbers have started continue to go
down
after schools were reopened what about
those who are of school age well you can
see
age two to year six starting to pick up
a little bit isn't it
age year seven to 11 starting to pick up
slightly more markedly
so some people will look at that and say
actually that's a cause for real concern
because those are starting to go up but
it is worth saying
first the data is pretty early and
second it's not all that clear so look
35 to 49 that's also going up
as well so is that really about school
age or is that something else
and then year 12 to age 24 look at that
line that's still going down
quite a bit as well so probably too
early to say but it does look like case
growth
might be starting to re-accelerate at
least for some age groups we'll have to
keep an eye
on those data in the next few weeks and
indeed months but that's the test three
so things looking kind of okay-ish on
that front
and then there's test four are new
variants a real concern
for the population remember new variants
which we've talked a lot about the uk
variant
the kent variant and other variants
indeed uh bristol liverpool all those
other things
what we can do here with this chart
actually i'm going to go on this side so
you can just see
the axis there what you can see is all
of those different variants now don't
worry that you
you know might not be able to make out
exactly which one is which
um for instance this one's the south
african variant not many new cases
uh on that one but the the long and the
short of it is
everything is totally dwarfed by i'll
add on b117
by this one so much dwarfed actually
that this chart isn't quite big enough
we're gonna have to zoom out
so we can see just how many cases there
are of that variant now basically
pretty much every case in the uk at the
moment is this kent variant
the uk variant um and the long and the
short of it is that pretty much all of
the other variants are really
really low at the moment so that's
pretty encouraging
on that front it's worth just saying
given that there's been broadly speaking
more encouraging than discouraging news
on this
it's worth just casting your mind back
to when we had that lockdown
announcement remember we had lots of
charts uh that were telling us that
things were going to be worse in the uk
than other countries well
have a look at this this shows you
covert cases uh per million
uh in different countries around europe
and what we're going to do is compare
the uk
to other countries so back at the time
lockdown was easy a lot of people were
concerned about the fact the uk was
pretty much the worst
uh in europe well here's where we were
there
very high up then it's come down very
sharply such that we're now actually one
of the lowest in europe what
is worth doing is just comparing the
uk's line there
to for instance france so france was
relatively low
around the kind of christmas period but
now it's started to rise up and i think
a lot of the focus
in the next few weeks and indeed months
will be on what happens in the
divergence of those two lines so the uk
really quite low at the moment
france starting to rise up also other
countries for instance sweden starting
to rise up there's always been a lot of
focus on sweden and what's going on with
their numbers
given the different way that they focus
with uh with their lockdown but sweden's
starting to rise
as well a lot of focus on that but also
on the fact that last time around you
know when we did have that lockdown
announcement
there were many projections saying that
you know if we weren't careful if we
eased too quickly we could start to see
things like this now this is from
an imperial projection about what might
happen to hospitalizations in the event
of various different scenarios you know
depending on how early we
ease lockdown and so on and each of
these different lines and the areas was
going to show you
what might happen to hospitalization so
this particular one and
the peak might have seen
hospitalizations of over 60 000
if things didn't work out as hoped but
what we can now do
is actually take the new data that we
have on hospitalizations because a bit
of time has passed
and superimpose it onto this chart and
see how we're doing and here is
how we're doing so look those black
lines there can you see
those black lines there those black dots
rather
are broadly speaking a little bit below
even the kind of better case scenarios
that we saw
here so this is pretty encouraging and
actually it kind of begs the question
you know
the focus has always been on data not
dates that was what boris johnson said
well here is some data suggesting we are
by some standards
doing even better than expected so does
that change the plan or lockdown at all
or do we just stick
to those existing dates